( music playing )
- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
Welcome to the end
of "The Super Slow Show."
That's right.
We've only rented these
shipping containers.
So everything from inside
of them has to go.
We've got a ton of props,
all our stuff.
- Clear up everything.
- It's a shame really.
- I've had a wonderful time.
- Yeah me, too.
Making the show.
Hopefully
you've enjoyed it, too.
I guess there's not really
much left to do
apart from pack it up.
- They're taking the mug.
- There goes the mug.
Need that bit of tape
that'll come in handy later.
- I was gonna use that
in the pool.
- Yeah.
You can see you still
have a work look.
My lab coats are dirty,
yours are clean.
This is Shawn, he has absolutely
nothing to do with paint
or anything but for some reason
he's covered in paint.
The weather's acting like
it's the end of the world.
There's a sandstorm
coming through.
It's about time
we got out of here to be honest.
- Oh, sound guy's annoyed still.
- Yep.
I mean his car never came back
in one piece.
I guess now things will just go
back to normal on this channel.
Back to the back garden.
Oh, it means I have
to clean up all the mess.
- Yeah.
- All the stunts.
I did all the stunts
anyway on this show.
- That's true.
- As you can see.
There's actually one more thing
we do have to take care of.
- What's that?
- They wanted us to empty
the pool before we left.
Well--
got an idea.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
The guys were clearing out
the shipping containers
and found a smidge
of spare det. cord.
Det--
how much det. cord?
Well in the experiment before
we used about a hundred feet.
- Yeah.
- Found 500 spare feet.
So we've got 500 feet
of det. cord.
- Yep.
- In the pool.
It's in the pool right now.
One in each corner.
100 feet in each corner
and one in the middle.
I feel a bit uneasy
staring into it to be honest.
- It's right there.
- Okay.
This is gonna go up
so I guess sort of--
- let's go over there.
- Safe distance.
- Way over.
- Let's go.
Let's do that right now.
Ready?
Three, two, one!
Gav:
That shifted some water.
Dan:
It's gonna go
into the camera.
- Save the Phantom.
- Save the Phant.
Phantom is now
by a river.
I'm quite happy
with that you know.
We got a lot of water
outta there.
- It blew the sides out.
- Whoa!
That's annihilated
the sides.
You know, it may have
been a lot of det. cord,
and it may displaced a fair
amount of water in the explosion
but it looks like most of it
landed by back in the pool.
Oh man.
So it's gone up
and then just straight
back down again.
That is not pretty.
Would you go for a swim
in that?
You can feel all the ground
under this is much looser now.
Oh, imagine
if you just fell in.
What if you just went in?
Oh dear.
Both:
Oh!
Gav:
That looks like it could be fun
to dive through now.
- What, after the explosion?
- Just like through
that column.
Dan:
You'd have to time it perfectly
or get blown up.
- Oh, dear!
- Whoa!
Dan:
It looks like jelly almost
at the edge.
Gav:
Oh, look at the wood getting
blown apart there.
It's almost like the wood
dampened the energy
of the explosion.
Just sent the water straight up
instead of out.
I think of the 30,000 gallons
in that pool,
we may lost a gallon
and a half.
- It looked good.
- Yeah.
Wasn't functional
in any way.
- That's what the man said,
right?
- Yeah.
Fancy walking off
into the sunset?
- Cute.
- Yeah.
So which way
to LAX then?
- LAX is over there I think.
- Over there.
- Yeah.
- All right.
( music playing )
- Hello, Gav here.
- I'm Dan.
Click here to watch Dan
get slammed by pro wrestlers.
I have no memory
of that.
You may have landed
on your head just a bit.
Is that why I woke up
in the woods?
No comment.